[Music]
welcome
to the week in 60 minutes brought to you
by spectator tv
and recorded on thursday february the
4th first up the uk's vaccine rollout
continues at pace
over 10 million vaccinated with the
first dose
at the latest count we'll bring you the
latest covet update as well as the
spectators
inside track on just how the uk has done
it
the rollout is a source of envy
especially across the channel
on friday the eu panicked decided to
close the irish border to stop
vaccines being exported to the uk then
immediately backtracked when the
enormity of its stupidity dawned on it
the spectator's political team will be
breaking down the fallout
we'll also take a look at the sacking of
joanna cherry the
snp mp who did to side with alex salmond
and the party's embrace of transgender
politics
from the party's front bench all these
issues
is the snp finally in some kind of
trouble
and the church of england it was in
decline before the pandemic
it's now an even faster decline that's
this week's
cover story on the spectator so all that
to come
in the next hour if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
and why wouldn't you it's free you never
miss a program just click the subscribe
button at the bottom right of the screen
now as always a very special thanks to
charles stanley
for their continued support of the week
in 60 minutes
charles sandler is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms and one
of the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange we're
delighted to be partners with them
now before the vaccine british pandemic
policy was marked by
repeated failures but his vaccine
rollout has become the envy of many
other countries especially
those across the channel kate andrews
joins us to bring us up to date with the
latest stats
she's the editor of the spectators daily
covert 19
update newsletter uh the only roundup
you really need for the latest
on the coronavirus pandemic in britain
and abroad
kate over to you thanks andrew at
yesterday's press conference chief
medical officer chris witte
said that the uk was past its peak of
this wave of the virus
and as you can see from this first slide
the data really reflects that
daily cases are now hovering around
where they were in early december when
england was coming out of its first
lockdown
and as spectator tv watchers will
remember from last week we looked at
hospitalization emissions
in the uk and those also appeared to be
on a downward trajectory but we were
cautious
knowing that these figures can be
revised upwards but it's a week later
and if we look at this next slide
we can see that decrease in emissions
very clearly now
still chris witty warned yesterday that
these figures were incredibly high in
his words
that the nhs was still at risk from
suffering capacity trouble
uh what he deemed as extraordinarily
fast in a bad circumstance
um i'm going to come back to that point
in just a minute what these decreases
could mean potentially for
lockdown easing but first i want to look
at the office for national statistics
antibody survey
as you can see on this next slide the
latest survey shows 15.3
antibody prevalence in england that's up
from 10.7
last month now back in the first wave an
increase
would suggest higher case numbers and
more circulation of the virus
this time around infections are
certainly playing their role again
especially with the more aggressive
strain the kent
strain of the virus but the exciting
news
is that vaccines are also playing their
part too now
as you can see from this next slide the
age breakdown
is really remarkable the highest
antibody positivity in england is for
the over 80s who of course have been
prioritized
for the vaccine roughly 25 of that age
group is now showing antibodies and
that's with a 95
confidence interval now this latest
survey runs 28 days
leading up to january 18th and we know
that it can take several weeks for
antibodies to kick in
once you've had the jab so this survey
is really looking at the beginning
stages
of the vaccine rollout which started on
the 8th of december it's accounting for
maybe up to a month but what's exciting
is that if we consider the fact that
what we're looking at here
is showing the beginning phases of the
rollout that would suggest in the next
survey
we could be seeing some extraordinary
figures that are taking into account the
millions of people
who have been getting their jobs and
building up antibodies
and the ons is going to be releasing
these surveys fortnightly now so we're
going to get to see
that vaccine factor play out soon
all of this bolsters the narrative that
the uk's procurement process
and rollout of the vaccine has been
right it's gotten its strategies
right a story which katie balls has
written up in the magazine this week and
i know is going to
be discussing in detail in a little bit
between the four nations as you can see
in this slide
we've reached the 10 million jab
milestone and the uk is still on track
to hit its mid-february target of the
first four priority groups
being vaccinated and there's now talk of
early april when the over
50s that's uh priority groups one
through nine would be
vaccinated so what does this all mean
for the easing of lockdown
well on the one hand you had even more
good news this week the
pre-print of an oxford trial published
in the landsat
which showed that the vaccine had a 76
efficacy rate that's
six percentage points higher than was
originally thought
and crucially that it seemed to cut
transmissions by two-thirds
now this last slide shows some sage
modeling which projected that vaccines
cutting transmissions by over 50 percent
could get deaths to near zero around
april though hospitalizations might
trail this
as under 65s make up roughly 65
of those in the icu right now of course
they are more likely
to recover but there's a catch in this
slide it's also assuming september style
restrictions
that means major social distancing rules
still in place
that's certainly not what we would call
normal
so as we hit these targets mid-february
the most vulnerable being inoculated
hopefully by early april the over 50s
being inoculated
pressure is going to mount on
politicians for society to start opening
up and there are major questions to be
answered
how low do hospitalization and death
rates have to be in order for us to
meaningfully
reopen and what is the tolerance for
risk
health secretary matt hancock told the
spectator just last month
that once the most vulnerable were
protected that we were going to cry
freedom but whether the government is
actually willing to make the case for
freedom
is a different story indeed back to you
andrew
uh just before you go kate um there's
been a lot of argument mainly from the
french about the
oxford vaccine and also some reports
that you could get vaccinated with say
pfizer for the first dose but a
different vaccine for the second just
tell us a bit more about that
sure those are two separate stories the
first is that there have been criticisms
from european leaders about the oxford
astrosenica vaccine
this is very strange given that the
european medicines agency has approved
the vaccine for all age groups but there
there's still some leaders
suggesting that we don't know enough
about it to say whether or not it would
protect
the most vulnerable i.e those in older
age groups the good news from that
pre-print oxford trial that we got this
week
is that the efficacy rate is thought
actually to be higher than we
originally estimated it to be all the
signs are still pointing in a positive
direction
for the oxford vaccine and i think what
you could take away as well is that
the the eu's desire to get more oxford
jabs into the block in their push to get
a higher order
it's going to be slightly undermined by
major european leaders including
emmanuel macron suggesting they're not
going to use it to inoculate their most
vulnerable why wouldn't you then
keep those jabs in the uk where we are
using it to inoculate
the elderly the second thing you
mentioned andrew is
a voluntary trial in which they're going
to look at what is essentially a vaccine
cocktail if you
give somebody one type of jab first and
another type of jab second to see if you
can
increase its effectiveness this is all
going to be voluntary
volunteers are going to know that
they're they're part of this trial it is
not going to be carried out as part of
the
major vaccine rollout to make sure
everyone's inoculated
so nobody needs to worry that that trial
is being conducted on them when they get
their vaccine
um everybody will know going into it
that they're in that trial and it's
exciting really it could be a real
discovery process if we find out that
mixing these vaccines together
can get a higher efficacy rate it means
people are better protected
okay the only unhappy person will be
president macron
uh but we don't really bother too much
about that
let's talk about the politics uh europe
blew a gasket last week over its failure
to order enough vaccines and rule them
out fast enough
leaving everybody but itself including
of course blaming
britain the brussels commission has
since backed off but hostilities are
still
lying just below the surface let's bring
in james forsyth
our political editor and katie bowles
our deputy political editor
to reflect on where we are now and how
the last week unfolded
james where are we now on relations
between brussels
and london i think things are pretty
tense still i mean there was
a certain amount of disbelief in
uh uk government circles about some of
the things that
eu leaders are saying so you had
emmanuel macron suggesting that the
oxford vaccine was
quasi ineffective in the over 65s uh
you've had uh ursula wanted the
commission president herself suggesting
that those countries that have
got vaccinating before the eu had failed
in their gigantic responsibility to
ensure the vaccines are safe and i think
there is a
certain amusement about this behavior
because there's a sense this is this is
this risks being not just
irresponsible but self-defeating on
behalf of eu leaders
because there are several countries in
the eu most notably france where there
is a large amount of anti-vaccine
sentiment so
statements like this kind of risk
inflaming that situation
uh and i think that that is the problem
uh and so i think that they've been
robbed foolhardy i think this is
all because the commission feels very
much on the back foot it's
worth remembering that a small group of
european countries
including france germany and holland had
started off on a vaccine procurement
program
uh last spring uh but then the
commission insisted on taking it over
and the criticism is that they
negotiated poorly
they didn't realize that the earlier you
sign these contracts the more time you
had to kind of
work out production difficulties and the
like and they negotiated
harder on price and indemnities and this
slowed the whole process down and i
think what really drove
the commission wild was when the ceo of
astrazeneca gave an interview
essentially setting out the things that
he felt the commission had done wrong
but the uk was getting more vaccine
because it had signed its contract
earlier which had given more time to set
things in place and i think that was
that the the commission were furious
about that and they were furious because
they thought this was going to stoke up
the criticism that the the vaccine
program was receiving particularly in
the
german press and so they then kind of
got into this slang match for
astrazeneca
they went to the lakes of publishing the
contract of astrazeneca which was
far from a slam dunk i actually think
weakened their case
and then they came up with this idea of
a kind of export transparency mechanism
and the idea of this was to ensure that
you know vaccines that were meant for
the eu
weren't being shipped out of the block
but i think the fact that the eu have
done this has caused it kind of
diplomatic
damage because it's hard to portray
yourself as a great defender of the
rules based international order when
you're doing things like this
and it also affects countries other than
the uk both canada
and japan have complained vociferously
about this
because they what they are expecting to
get
and have contracted to get uh vaccines
that are being produced within the eu
james they they backed off the eu backed
off over
uh the northern ireland border when it
realized
the road it was going down but is it is
it not true to say that brussels the
commission
still expects to be informed
of to be given details of any vaccines
that are going to be exported out of the
eu
yes and they still have a mechanism in
place where if the commission and the
member state agree
the the the export could be blocked or
stopped
now they say this is just to make sure
that uh companies aren't saying to them
i'm terribly sorry we haven't got enough
supply to supply you
while sending the vaccines elsewhere but
it is obviously
clearly a kind of protectionist measure
now in that in
in their friday night phone call ursula
wonderland promised boris johnson that
the uk's
fisa deliveries would not be
held up by this regime but i think this
is
this is a tension that is not going to
go away
and i think that there is i mean there
will be considerable nervousness on
other countries parts now
of contracting with firms that are uh
building their vaccines in the eu
because it's not hard to imagine a
situation where
the the eu rollout continues at this
slow pace there's more and more
criticism
and the eu starts saying well we're
going to keep all the vaccine produced
in the block
for use in the block qt the
a lot of tough rhetoric coming out of
europe but the british government's been
pretty restrained
indeed the conservative politicians in
general have been quite restrained
about this what's what's going on here
why why are they so well behaved
under orders i think if if you look at
ministers i think there's been a very
conscious effort from uh you know
the highest uh echelons of government
ultimately to say let's not get involved
in this tip for tat
now initially i think it was for a few
reasons i think that the uk government
were very keen this state is an
argument between astrazeneca as a
company and the eu as a block
rather than what the eu seem to be
pushing into into
which is the idea of the uk is ahead of
us and
that is a problem so they wanted it to
remain a contractual dispute boris
johnson kept playing it down
i think however as we have seen uh the
eu leaders macronus has mentioned uh
cast doubt on the oxford vaccine i think
that's been harder to hold up you have
started to hear
the occasional number 10 schools talk
about is it really such a great idea
for countries with lots of vaccine
skepticism to have their leaders
in a way stoking it but almost as far as
you're going to get because even though
the uk vaccination program is going very
well the message from the whips to tory
mps is ultimately please don't go in the
airwaves and
use this to as you know uh look this is
why brexit's so great and this is why
the eu is suffering
they really don't want a triumphalist
tone and they want to look as though
they are the adults in the room
but the the british must have been a bit
surprised but there was always a
trumpian tone to what
some of the european politicians were
saying from president macron
saying effectively saying you can't
really trust this
oxford astrazeneca uh vaccine to the
germans saying we're not
going to give it to people over 65 i
mean
it is the kind of stuff that we were
used to when mr trump was in the white
house we never
thought we'd hear that coming out of the
lizi palace or from german politicians
yeah i mean i think they've been very
surprised by it and i think that
ultimately the the level of seniority
and also people going on the record we
mentioned macron but you know other
ministers in france
and the decision ultimately in countries
such as sweden not to approve the
oxford vaccine or to advise against it
for the over 60
so it has taken people by surprise in
government however i think that they
believe actually
events will soon overtake which shows
that they are on the right side
so at the moment uh as kate was showing
in
the graphs we're at point where we're
still waiting for the effects of some of
these vaccines to come through that is
expected
um but for example you know i i've had a
minister to say that
they believe in a few weeks time macron
will be shown to be completely wrong
and all these eu countries also
completely wrong in this over 60s and at
that point you
don't need to have war of words because
the science will have spoken for itself
i look forward to president macron's
full apology
but i won't hold my breath james the
the politics of this on the tory back
benches on the one hand they'll be
very pleased that the government has
finally got something
very big very right we haven't seen that
before but on the other hand they'll be
championing at the bit i
assume saying well if it's all going so
well and we're gonna
have most of the vulnerable vaccinated
before this month is out
and getting to the rest of the community
thereafter
why can't we live locked down sooner and
as i understand it james
the government's anxious to resist that
yes i think boris johnson is
very keen to go slowly to ensure that
this is the last lockdown
i also think that he doesn't want to
once again
over promise and unders under deliver uh
so i think what he wants to do is to
is to surprise people on the upside in
the way that they have with the pace of
vaccinations
uh with the pace of lockdown lifting but
that that's creating attention because
his mps are saying to him look come on
uh the whole point of vaccinating people
is to reopen society so
let's set a a bold timetable for doing
that
and then i'm i quote in the magazine
this week one cabinet means the same
thing look
the problem is despite all the support
schemes
at some point businesses are going to
run out of money unless they can reopen
at some point soon so
i think you will begin to see as the
death numbers begin to fall quite
dramatically
and the issue becomes as kate said what
more of hospital capacity even of deaths
you know a concerted kind of tory push
for a quicker
easing of lockdown um one thing that is
making it tricky for boris johnson is
but you know scottish primary schools
will go back two weeks before
english primary schools and i think
we've seen as we saw with the tory
revolt over the rule of six where you
know in scotland
uh children of primary school age were
excluded from it
uh when when boris johnson can't say
look
i'm going faster than everyone else in
the you know in the devolved
administrations
he has a particular trouble with his uh
back benches uh but i think the kind of
question now
but i think another crucial point is if
this
uh oxford cutting transmission by
two-thirds
if that evidence holds up and is borne
out in the vaccination stats
i think we could be looking at a much
quicker return
to normality than we expect
interesting well we shall see that would
please lots of people
uh katie you've got a fascinating piece
in the magazine this week which looks at
why did the brits get the vaccine
strategy right
so far we're not there yet but it uses
uh it doesn't get worse every day it
seems in some ways to get better
and there are a number of things you
identified a vaccine tax
task force getting the right people
uh on to that task force particularly
the head of it
and and also ordering a lot of stuff
with very robust contracts talk us
through
the background to our success yes so as
you say
we're not there yet it's still in the
middle of it but i think
ultimately you're increasingly hearing
figures in government talk about the
vaccine task force the vaccine success
stories so far
as something they can learn from in
terms of future endeavors
all across the spectrum now i think to
understand how it came about we've got
to remember ppe
and the debacle over ppe uh soon after
the pandemic we were told there was
plenty of ppe the public help
public health england had a plan but
quite quickly you saw this global
scrabble
for a resource which everyone wanted and
was unlimited supply
contracts rendered meaningless and
ultimately quite painful for the
government
there are stories about planes uh you
know on the way that never quite landed
and and so forth
and i think patrick valance chief
scientific officer quite early on from
that
uh realized that the vaccine approach
was going to have to be different
now this is not just because pve had
gone so badly but because
vaccine procurement isn't just about
medicine it's clearly complicated
contracts
and there a case was made to boris
johnson that they would need to get a
vaccine start
in the in the form of kate bingham the
person he chose
i think probably the most instrumental
thing though was looking at ppe
and the shortages there is an early
recognition i think across the cabinet
of vaccine nationalism
which is why when oxford are going to
partner with merck the american company
it was vetoed and you got the
astrazeneca contract instead that was
bulked up even more with an intervention
from patrick valance number 10
saying in a way to get this uh you know
royal and best efforts
to get this steady supply let's give oxf
oxford astrazeneca something and that
therefore let's pay for lots of that
manufacturing
and so you're starting to see what
formed a lot of this uh
whole strategy which is where you can
manufacture in the uk
and then i think from that ultimately
what patrick valencia pushed very hard
to have was have
figures from the private sector join
civil servants not just have it
stay within and bring expertise and you
had kate bingham leading that force but
lots of players along the road and
also the military um which i think every
time you now call
a figure involved in this they're very
keen to say the army just know how to
get things done
um and all coming together but i think
what it does show is
even though vaccines are not seen by
many in government as the most likely
way out
partly because they can take a very long
time what this task force had to do was
act as though
they were coming even if they hadn't
been green lit yet so how are you going
to manufacture something which
isn't yet approved and might never be
approved and therefore that's a
different approach they had to use
and yes you had met hancock pushing for
more doses for everyone
but you also had rishi sunak the chance
of supporting this approach
i think partly because of his background
and investments so treasury officials i
think in documents called
a very unorthodox model um because
rather than trying to get value for
money and going for the lowest rates
you're
ultimately chucking resources at lots of
things and hoping that one of them
sticks
and katie i understand that the
government is so taken by its own
success on this that
it's looking at what happened with the
vaccine tax
force and various other things
associated with that how it was done
the role of the private sector the role
of a sort of vaccine czar
uh the importance of getting robust
contracts which governments are
often not very good at negotiating
rolling all that up
it sees quite fundamental lessons
in this for other areas of uh government
in the future
yes so there's a treasury report we
understand yeah and
currently unpublished where it talks
about this as a potential blueprint for
the
strategy going forward and i've spoken
to ministers
who ultimately you know pose a question
saying yes we managed to
be efficient for once in a pandemic but
can we not be efficient all the time
and i think that therefore we might
start to see a push and it's interesting
because i think
some of this is parallels if you think
back to dominic cummings and some of
the civil service reform he wanted to do
um but start to see
where you can bring in more private
expertise and i think that
consultants have had a bad name
throughout this crisis partly because of
things like the ppe scandal
but i think what the vaccine task force
shows is
there is a type of outside expertise
that is really valuable and perhaps it's
about
working at that rather than you know
just offshoring lots of things
and it might have been all so different
if uh
health secretary matt hancock hadn't
seen the film contagion
yes so this is how we know we're in
expert hands uh
early on early on the crisis matt
hancock could i think
who needs consultants when you've got
netflix
exactly i'm yet to watch it but that's
my weekend uh in lockdown sorted
um but yeah having seen the film
contagion
very early on in meetings um i think as
far back as january february and vaccine
was not
the first and forefront uh thing of
being focused on
and matt hancock was saying look we need
to think about preparing for this and
then later on
that final uh part of the film is where
eventually there is a vaccine
but there is a lottery because it's a
limited supply and apparently this is
what motivated the health secretary to
order big
to say that we need to get as many doses
as possible and
so contagion has helped us all
apparently very well
all right james let me finish up with
you on this segment of the show
we talked in previous weeks last week
the week before about how
the vaccination policy was also the
economic policy they needed to work to
be able to
open up the economy again looking at the
polls with the tories now ahead of labor
again
looks to me like the vaccine policy is
also the government's political policy
as well
yeah i mean the vaccine is by far the
most important thing in british politics
right now
you know just imagine where we would be
if there wasn't a vaccine you know the
cabinet would be irrevocably split
between those
who felt that we had to learn to live
with the virus and those who wanted more
lockdowns on public health grounds
you know i think public morale would be
on the floor people would have passed
that terrible hundred thousand deaths
mark
and with just a grim sense that there
were more of these awful milestones to
come
and i think that the crucial thing here
is that
if the uk gets out of restrictions
and gets its hospitals cleared before
other neighboring countries then i think
the people people will think oh well
hang on a second
yes the government have got things wrong
in this crisis and they undoubtedly have
but we are out of it earlier and i mean
that because of you know we know that
people remember the most
put the most store on what has happened
to them most recently
i mean that will probably cast the
government's handling of this pandemic
in a more positive light
i also think if the uk is out of
restrictions uh because of its
vaccination program before
uh most eu countries i think that will
that will help boris johnson say look
you know
i've got brexit done and there are
benefits to it
and also the other big problem families
apprenticeship is going to be the union
with these
scottish parliament elections later this
year and i think that you know if the uk
state has managed to do this and to roll
out the vaccine
to to buy the vaccines to help develop
the vaccines
i mean i mean there will be a benefit
for the union in that too
all right we tee up our next uh segment
which is on
scotland and the union but james and
katie we thank you for that we'll let
you go now james forsyth has done
his weekly political column on what he
was just talking about there as always
it's worth a read
and katie's uh article is on the
background to the success
of the british vaccine program why it
did
go right so far fingers crossed now
scotland's a ruling snp
is in trouble on several fronts but it
doesn't
seem to dent nicholas sturgeon's
popularity at least
not so far she's still easily favored to
win scotland's may
elections however she is increasingly
assailed on all sides
from alex simon's claims that she was
part of a conspiracy
to do him down to scotland mp
joanna cherry who this week was fired
from a front bench position
uh also to criticism that the rollout of
the vaccine
north of the border is not going quite
as smoothly as it is elsewhere in the uk
to unrest among the more fundamental
among her
rank and file who thinks she's not
moving fast enough
for a second referendum so a lot they're
building in
but nicolas sturgeon still well ahead in
the polls
and the only question seeming to be how
well
will she do come the hollywood elections
in may
let's discuss all this with the
spectators scotland editor alex massey
and spectator contributor and columnist
for the scottish daily mail stephen
daisler
gentlemen welcome to you both alex let
me come
to you first it is right to say but
putting aside the impact that it's
having whether there's much
fallout there's much cut through that
that
the the government the scot gov and
nicholas sturgeon they
are a little bit beleaguered at the
moment yes i mean as you
rightly suggest there is a paradox at
work here on the one hand the snp
continued to register support running at
around 50
in all the opinion polls uh a level of
support that means
the outcome of may's hollywood elections
assuming they
go ahead as planned and the first
minister is very keen that they do
uh the the uh the argument there uh is
will the smp win an overall majority or
will they
uh have to make do for what they
currently have which
is a very strong minority administration
there where they
can often count on support from the
green party to ensure there is a
pro-independence majority
in the scottish parliament um and yet as
you rightly say
there are any number of different
arguments on multiple fronts
taking place in the snp at the moment as
you some of this
is a small number of people who are
supporters of alex simon who feel that
he's been stitched up by his successor
and the ongoing fallout from that could
yet cause significant difficulties for
nicolas sturgeon
some of it is about the sort of
progressive or what some people term a
woke agenda on gender recognition trans
uh
gender rights um and some of it is
yes well what how are we going to
actually force boris johnson
to hold a referendum on independence
that he that we think he might lose
why would he do that what's in it for
him uh and so all of these things
contribute to a situation which is
remarkably febrile in scottish
politics even though the actual outcome
of the
election in may is pretty much not in
doubt
you know the snp are going to win the
question is how big they win
but within that there are any number of
discontents and fischer's opening
some of which short-term problems for
nicola sturgeon and the s movement more
generally
some of which could be quite serious in
the longer term
stephen is there any sign even just at
the margins
the the problems crowding in on the
first minister
are becoming corrosive or or is she
totally impervious to it
well i i think has um probably came
across quite well in alex's answer there
nicholas sturgeon is doing great in the
polls perhaps not so great in the
politics behind the polls
um in terms of her position she is in a
in a relatively strong position given
that although she doesn't have a
majority of hollywood she can rely on
the greens
there is a great deal of support behind
her within the the institutional party
um and much within the parliamentary
party she's also strengthened by the
fact that there isn't
really an immediate alternative and
the uh those who could um potentially
replace her
are actually people who are of the
suitable caliber i would say
to be able to step into that role
largely speaking
um at least within holy radar are those
who are sympathetic to her
um that is not to say that there aren't
problems there are very much problems
alex just went through them
i think that there is also a sense
that nicola sturgeon has talked a very
good game uh on many fronts she's talked
a good game on on
forcing the the uk to allow a second
independence referendum
she talked a good game on covid um and
now we're starting to see the
as the rubber hits the road moment um
where you see the uh
the uh we've transitioned from the kind
of the rhetoric
to the actual delivery and whether it's
on a second independence referendum or
it's on uh the vaccine rollouts where
uh scotland is is behind all of the
other nations
of the uk in rolling out the vaccine
um you are seeing that the delivery is
not matching up to the rhetoric
and so while her politically and
institutionally
um her position is relatively strong
just now
and you can see the the fissure is
absolutely opening up
alex the the one thing if looking in
from the outside
the one thing that is surprising and did
i put it stronger than that it's kind of
jaw-dropping
is that in the inquiry the hamilton
inquiry the irish qc into whether or not
nicholas sturgeon misled the house over
this
over alex salmond and the process and
then the parliamentary inquiry into the
broader areas of the salmon of the whole
salmon business
the amount of information that would
normally be in the public realm
is not in the is not allowed to be put
into the public realm
even the submissions of important
figures
in the saga which have been submitted to
the parliament
are not allowed to publish that
information are
people aware in scotland of how much is
being suppressed
i think i mean you may raise a you know
number of excellent points there andrew
uh the answer the short answer to your
question is is no
there is a widespread feeling that
although
the political and media class is very
interested in the nuts and bolts of this
issue the general public remains fairly
indifferent to it
that is partly because there is
obviously a sense i suppose that the
pandemic in its management is a rather
greater
uh matter than what happened between
alex salmond and nicola sturgeon a
number of years ago and who said what
what
was said at what meeting etc etc etc all
of which becomes very detailed very
quickly and very difficult to
to cut through um you know there still
isn't a
sound bite-sized charge against nicola
sturgeon
save that she has quite possibly
and possibly on multiple occasions at
best misled
the hollywood parliament and quite
possibly lied to it
whether that would i mean traditionally
obviously that would if if
confirmed if proved if accepted would
traditionally count as a
resignation matter but nicola sturgeon's
poll ratings and amongst the public as a
whole
not just snp supporters and it's
important i think to stress that
are such that i think quite a lot of
people could be persuaded that
ordinary circumstances do not apply just
now
and that she could conceivably survive
uh a scandal that would have destroyed
all her predecessors but you are
absolutely right also to suggest that
the way her government has handled this
inquiry having initially promised its
full cooperation
has uh persuaded an awful lot of people
i think that there must
actually be something more to it than
meets the eye
because a government that really had
nothing to hide uh first minister who
really was
you know prepared to cooperate with the
inquiry to the fullest possible extent
simply wouldn't be behaving like this um
you know so it leads one to think that
there is something being covered up
now the question then becomes is it a
catalogue of
incompetence that has been covered up or
a catalogue of malice
that is being covered up or some uh
mixture of the two in proportions we
don't yet know
um but you know it is an excellent
example of how not uh to run these
affairs i think if you're going to
to have a parliamentary inquiry and if
you are going to take credit
for your supposed candor and frankness
in establishing an inquiry into yourself
then you really do have to follow
through on that and cooperate with it
properly
and that clearly has not been the case
in this instance
stephen one of the things that does
surprise us is if you take some key
submissions that this parliamentary
inquiry has asked from for crucial
businesses
one from jeff aberdeen who was uh alex
simon's chief of staff and was involved
in
a particularly crucial meeting with the
nicolas sturgeon
uh way back in 2018 and i take it to the
pilot's point
that a lot of this is kind of uh almost
ruatarian in its uh
information in his complexity
but the point is that this was this is a
submission to a
parliamentary inquiry but the
parliamentary inquiry has decided
he's unable to publish that evidence i
have been told
that alex salmon's submission to the
public inquiry
that that may not be published either
and that indeed he is worried about even
testifying before this inquiry in case
on some areas
he's found to be in contempt of court
i mean to be honest he just wouldn't get
away with that in westminster
i think that that is a valid point um
it's important to separate out the
issues so um one of the issues
is of course the question of jigsaw
identification which is you know i think
we all agree very important
this is of the the women who complained
that eventually
led to uh alexander's trial uh
and uh the importance of protecting the
anonymity of the complainers
yes absolutely and so a good example of
that was
um the the committee has uh had to
slightly drag it out of the crown office
but it got access to
to whatsapp messages um which it has
uh said that the committee said it
wouldn't publish to to the general
public
um because it views them as a a support
group of women who were supporting each
other
um and that that wouldn't be appropriate
obviously um to to publish that
there is the issue of jigsaw
identification but if we put that to one
side
there is um a a broader question
about um how forthcoming um
the the scottish government has been
willing to be um
with documents and how robust the
committee has been
in attempting to secure um some of those
um productions and there is a sense
that the uh that the committee is simply
and not robust enough is not strong
enough in itself
to um to force the uh
the scottish government to produce some
of these um documents and
you know that is i think one of the
unfortunate you know facts is that
the committee has um
although some has done some diligent
work and you know uh all credited to it
for doing that
but uh there are some who wonder if this
is simply a committee that was
chosen as the forum for investigating
this matter because
it would not be able to get to the truth
because it would not be powerful enough
to uh to hold the scottish government to
account well it's certainly ironic
alex that this committee doesn't seem to
have the necessary
teeth to do a proper inquiry because i
mean i was in scotland when the
parliament was set up
and the supporters of devolution their
great boast was
our our committees are going to have
real teeth you know we we won't have a
second chamber
uh in the scottish parliament instead we
will have
committees that will scrutinize
legislation before it goes
before the house will hold the
politicians to contem
to to account and yet here alex you have
a situation where
you can turn up and testify under oath
it turns out what you said wasn't true
and instead of facing uh the force of
the law for testifying wrongly under
oath
you're asked to come back and put the
record straight
and if you don't feel like it you say i
can't be bothered i'm not coming back
i mean again in a major select committee
in westminster
that would just never happen uh that
that's true um
you know again lots of things going on
simultaneously
um the committee structure at hollywood
is too weak i think there is a general
acceptance of that at hollywood route
it is two week partly because as well it
is
um these committees are staffed by
people who are not themselves
particularly capable uh it doesn't have
proper legal counsel
not ironic got a proper legal counsel
um but yeah well indeed they're
insufficiently staffed as well and
resourced
um you know it is a major institutional
failing of the scottish parliament and a
devolution settlement if you like at
present
there are occasions when when committees
do do some better work i mean for
instance the
the scottish government's proposed hate
crime bill that is
proving extremely controversial as well
has essentially been gutted
um even before it's uh been put to the
the floor of the parliament and in part
that is because of the work of
of the the justice committee that has
been analyzing it but overall
yes you have a problem in scotland of an
over mighty executive
and an enfield legislature um and
uh that it that it that is then perhaps
also combined with as you
know well from your own experience um
and in fee board scottish press that
lacks the resources sometimes to
to cover parliament properly and a
broadcast media
in scotland that has also is also much
diminished compared to
where it was a generation ago in terms
of uh the scrutiny
it is prepared to to apply to whoever
happens to be
in in power in in edinburgh at the
moment obviously
that is the the smp and they've been
empowered for 14 years which
you know i think one can make a
plausible argument is long enough
um and you see not not whether one
agrees with the snp or not per se
simply that after 14 years in government
if you have not achieved your
initial objectives it's extremely
unlikely that you are going to
um and all governments uh run out of
steam
of ideas and the ability the capacity to
reinvent themselves and i think
we're seeing a lot of that with nicolas
sturgeon's government at the moment as
well
which accounts for some of the sort of
frustration and this sort of curious
sense again as we got was
as we were saying at the beginning where
on the one hand scottish politics is
extremely stable
you know the snp first everyone else
nowhere and yet within that
there is an enormous amount of strife
and instability
uh and inside the snp and more generally
in scottish politics it is if you like a
sort of
caledonian anticipatory of our times
yes indeed stephen you your doc
crucial documents that should be in the
public domain being
massively redacted crucial submissions
to a
public inquiry not being published
the crown office seemingly using
jigsaw identification with in the
broadest possible interpretation
in ways that sometimes defy logic
to close down information becoming
public that they don't want
to become public if that was happening
in london i couldn't see the
the london press london media putting up
with this
is the scottish media just too supine
well i i think that there is um first of
all alex identified some of the
important structural
issues you know scotland is obviously
it's a smaller country we have
um fs even proportionally we probably
have um
uh less in the way of a media landscape
um
we you know you could argue the the
media is uh less adversarial i'm talking
about broadcast media here
um there is less of a there's there is
no sort of a robert peston or
uh laura koonsberg um sort of figure
who's
um uh you know is seen as a thorn in the
side of the government of the day
whoever that is
um and also you know there is the the
point as i say as alex makes that the
um the scottish media just lacks a lot
of the resources
um you know it's it's not i know some
people think there's some
conspiracy that the scottish press
doesn't want to to investigate the snp
that you know
it is much more the the fact that there
is just not this the the same bodies on
the ground that they're once where
and you know you know yourself from um
you know that the scottish
press and was once you know prided
itself on its robustness
and you know having armies of reporters
they could send in
um you know not so much now i i think
this is probably
um this is probably showing up the um
the real trouble you get into when you
don't have a robust
well-staffed well-funded adversarial
media
and where you have a government uh that
is in trouble in all
sorts of fronts um and yet you know on
what is you know as you see if this were
happening in westminster this would be
uh
not only would be national news i i've
arguably international news
uh that is you know not happening in
scotland it is as alex and you've also
alluded to
it's barely cutting through with people
and so i think this does show what
happens when you know of a robust media
um and that is uh uh
i think that that highlights the problem
you know that we have several democratic
flaws in scotland the the parliament is
too weak
the the press is too weak and the the
government is not held to account enough
let me just finish on the uh the
post-election politics uh
starting with alex and then i'll come
back to you stephen let's assume that
nicholas sturgeon
wins that's not a dangerous assumption
maybe she doesn't get quite that overall
majority
but she's still clearly the winner of
the election
and clearly the next first minister
up does she do you think alex does she
have a plan
in her mind a strategy over what to do
about a second referendum
no no is the the simple answer to that i
mean you know
the the argument will be that she has
the moral authority
to to press for a second direct second
independence referendum that brexit is
the kind of change in circumstance
that justifies revisiting the national
question
six seven eight years after it was
notionally decided
in 2014. and even if you're opposed to
the smp's plans i think one has to
accept that there is a certain moral
force to that argument
uh against that however it is only six
seven eight years since uh the there was
a referendum
and it is also i think morally plausible
um and morally just to argue that it is
too soon to reopen that question because
referendums have to have meaning
and that means the results have to be
given meaning otherwise you're into the
never-ending world
which is of little use to most people
and so you have
a collision between plausible arguments
it seems to me
and uh in the absence of consensus that
there should be
a referendum on independence and that
consensus remember
existed in 2012 which allowed the 2014
referendum to take place
in the in the absence of that consensus
it seems to me that it is very difficult
to proceed with one
even if you have the legal right to do
so
even if the courts confirmed that you
could because it has to be
a a gold standard referendum to use the
smp's own phrase
and that means replicating most of the
conditions that applied in 2014
and as i say i think one of the chief
ones of those is the consent of those
who do not want independence you know
the unions you could
if unionists agreed that there should be
a referendum there would be no problem
but you know we all have to live in the
scotland that happens
after it and so therefore the referendum
itself i think
has to take place at a time when there
is widespread acceptance and agreement
that it is a suitable moment for it and
we are still
some way off that you know the just say
no approach which the prime minister is
duty-bound to follow
is clearly subject to the laws of
diminishing returns because every year
that you move
away from 2014 is a year closer to a
time when it might be okay to revisit
the question but for the time being it
seems to me there is just enough juice
remaining to be extracted from that
position and there is frankly very
little i think that nicola sturgeon
can do about that and concocting plans b
c d e f g all the way to z if necessary
and so
doesn't actually change that fundamental
dynamic
which is that there isn't at present a
way for her to force the referendum
and so we are then stuck in a kind of
waiting pattern
in which nationalists rather like mr
micawber are waiting for something to
turn up that will
bring them the referendum and unionists
for their part are waiting for something
to turn up
that will either shoot the referendum
fox or
if there is a referendum uh caused the
nationalists to you
to lose it um and so we're again in this
sort of febrile state in scottish
politics
where everything is possible but nothing
ever changes
all right final brief thought on this
from you stephen before we move on
uh well i think that uh i would largely
agree that there is
very little nicola sturgeon can do the
snp has come out with this
so-called road map to a referendum and
the
um proposition in this is that they will
just simply if they win a majority in
may they'll bring forward a referendum
and essentially dare the the uk
government to try and stop them in the
courts if they if they
if they feel they can i think that's
more about ginning up the national space
ahead of the election
and there's very little very little
leeway here for the snb
the constitution is reserved and if
boris johnson doesn't want to give a
referendum if the uk parliament doesn't
want to have to give that
doesn't want to give one it doesn't have
to give one all right john's been plenty
to keep you busy north of the border
thank you for your time
today for joining us here on spectator
tv
we now turn to our final segment for
this week the pandemic has been tough
for many institutions and organizations
as well as people
big names like debenhams to the national
trust have been forced to make
deep cuts but you might not have
expected the church of england to be
among those
making cuts but it is spectator's cover
piece this week
takes a look at the proposed
redundancies to be made to anglican
ministers is this the death knell of a
church of england which has of course
already been struggling for decades the
reverend marcus walker joins the show
he's the rector
of great saint bartholomew's church in
the city of london
and he contributes to the magazine this
week on this
topic uh thank you for joining us
reverend the
the piece two pieces included make clear
the pandemic has been a problem for the
church of england
is it fair to say that it has hastened
its decline
i think it's fair to say that it might
hasten its decline
the question is very much what we do
afterwards
and that really depends on what the
parishioners choose to do
when all the churches in the country are
back open
and this the pandemic has cost uh the
church money though hasn't it because
it's not been able to do the same kind
of collections that you would normally
expect i think i read in our cover story
article that
the church gets about a billion pounds
in in collections
uh through the year that has obviously
been
been slashed so there are financial
troubles uh
for the church too oh absolutely i mean
most
churches have well all churches were
closed by law
in the first lockdown and many churches
have been closed now in this
third lockdown in between that you've
had an awful lot of people who just
haven't been able to come into church
because they're shielding or they
haven't felt safe
so the people physically in church have
been diminished and the ability to pass
around the plate where you can't pass
around the plate that also would be
illegal right now
um but the ability to metaphorically
pass around the plate has been
diminished
and an awful lot of churches aren't
using the advantages afforded us by
digital means to be able to fundraise as
well
would it be fair or would it be unfair
to say that in particular in the case of
the church of england
the church's voice has been too weak
during this pandemic
that during a time when people may be
looking for some spiritual solace for
some faith
for some help through dark times we
the people who are looking for that have
not heard
enough from the church of england
sadly i would say there's a truth to
that um
in the first lockdown a decision was
made by the bishops that
not just should the cler should churches
be closed as the law demanded but also
that we shouldn't do that which the law
allowed us which was for
clergy to go into their parishes and to
broadcast their services from inside
those buildings
and for the buildings to be open for
funerals for people who had
well died of coved or indeed anything
else and the bishops decided to forbid
even that
which diminished the capacity of
churches to respond
on a pastoral level and on a national
level
i think we very much lacked a voice
speaking into the horror of a pandemic
and discussing the realities of death in
a way that we haven't felt as a nation
since the second world war
and it seems that the cuts that are
being made
are going to hit the poorer diocese most
of all
where well first of all one would think
that with christianity that the poor are
the priority
but secondly that uh that is where the
help is probably most needed as well as
well
absolutely it's very interesting there
was a leaked document in the sunday
times
of this week in which the church of
england was mapping out
the responses that it was expecting to
take um
anticipating a twenty percent fall in uh
revenues well twenty percent fall in
people returning uh to church which i
think is probably
pessimistic but that's their
anticipation and they
asked whether it was whether it was now
was the time
to stop supporting what they call
subsidized parishes
and it will come as no surprise to you
to learn that subsidized parishes means
poorer parishes um and i think you're
absolutely right
if there's one body of people whom the
church should be for first and foremost
it's the poor and if there's one group
of parishes whom the rest of us should
be supporting
it's the poorer parishes we would seem
logical and indeed almost compulsory for
a christian church
to to take that view emma thompson the
the author of the other piece
the cover piece in the spectator this
week she's a volunteer in the church i
was interested in the picture that she
painted of almost a suffocating
bureaucracy
uh is that fair i mean it
because one doesn't think you know there
could be lots of criticisms with the
church of england they're often made
about the lines it takes
its emphasis on various things you don't
think of it as bureaucratic
is it in your view i mean you definitely
do think of it as bureaucratic if you're
inside it
is that right really as as every year
goes by more and more elements of
bureaucracy get added to it
um both in terms of the paperwork that
they're expecting
parishioners priests and parishioners to
fill in if they want to be involved in
anything
but also in terms of this burgeoning
exploding middle management
um just at the same time they're cutting
out
elements of the um of the um
of the frontline services so for example
um manchester diocese decided
two three months ago to advertise for
seven area deans this is a sort of
middle management area
previously it was a position that was
held by buggins turn it was the oldest
priest in the area who sort of
went up and told the bit you know it was
a sort of foreman and went up and said
oh
you know my priests aren't that happy
about this sermon or something
but now it's become a full-time job
detached from a parish
that which is because of all the
bureaucracy that's got added
now at that middle level chelmsford
that's cutting 60
priests yes making 60 priests redundant
by the end of this year with another 80
on a watch list
has doubled the number of archdeacons
again another sort of
middle tier formerly known as the oculi
episcopy the eyes of the bishop
but what are those double numbers of
archdeacons going to be arch deaconing
with all the priests being sacked and i
see that despite the cuts and and the
falling on the
poorest diocese that you mentioned in
your article that new roles are still
being created
one is for a director of justice peace
and integrity of creation
this may be naive but i would have
thought that every
minister of the cloth in the church of
england should be
they are directors of justice peace
and integrity isn't all of that
integral to christianity yes you would
think so
um and that they should have the
theological acumen to be able to work
out
what they can do with the big questions
about justice peace
and the integrity of creation and if
they've got particular things that they
need a bit of
help with for resources there are vast
numbers of
charities pressure groups and think
tanks that they could go to to ask
for help and advice that don't need to
be funded
on a diocese by diocese level in the
church of england
um but i think there's a feeling
whenever
there's often a feeling we need to be
seen to be doing something about
these issues and so create a post is
always the answer
could you see just finally to you
reverend
could you see a better way forward when
the pandemic's over
can you see a better way forward where
the church begins to it gets his
act together yes i think
the real treasure of the church of
england is its laity as its people and
both the people who actually go to
church
and also the vast reservoir of affection
that so many people in the country still
have for it even if they only go at
christmas
and easter see andy christians rather
than crv
there's that vast reservoir of support
and there's a vast reservoir of
experience you've got
in the pews great politicians like
theresa may you've got great journalists
like um
oh gosh the editor of private eyes names
just completely i'll escape you've got
great bankers finances
um people who can work who actually know
how to deal with
numbers let's harness the people who
actually go to church
and who love the church of england and
let's work out
actually how to prioritize them
the people on the ground the volunteers
the poor
who can get quite you know a heck of a
lot of support from the richer parishes
and the richer people are attending
neighbouring churches
rather that and and we can cut down on
all the panicked bureaucracy in the
middle
and focus on what we really need to be
doing that's where we should be going
that's what our priority should be
sounds very sensible reverend and uh
thank you marcus walker for being on
spectator tv
uh and uh sharing these thoughts with us
remember the cover story
this week is about the church of england
and the problems it has been facing
during the pandemic that's it for this
week thanks to our
very special sponsor charles stanley uh
they continue to sponsor the week in 60
minutes we're very grateful charles
stanley one of the
uk's leading wealth management firms is
one of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange we love
having them
as our partners a final reminder that if
you subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel it's
free you never miss another episode you
just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
right of the screen
now as always send us any thoughts you
have
to spectator tv spectator dot co dot uk
that's spectator
tv spectator dot co dot uk
that's it for this week join us again
next week bye
[Music]
you